là monsieur bonsoir version moderne donc
que des contes de fées aujourd'hui à
barcelone ce n'est pas un berger qui a
épousé une princesse mais un sportif
professionnel star du handball espagnol
qui a dit oui à la fille cadette de juan
carlos un mariage salué par tout un
peuple qui contrairement à ce que l'on a
pu constater en angleterre est très
proche de la famille royale une famille
moderne qui vit simplement dont les
enfants travailler cette affection s'est
ressentie à l'occasion des cérémonies
martine laroche-joubert voile de
dentelle blanche retenu par un diadème
de diamants bouquets de lys propre sans
fioritures le mariage l'infante cristina
d'espagne à l'image de la monarchie
espagnole mélange de faste et de
simplicité
la cérémonie célébrée dans la cathédrale
de barcelone
construite en 1040 6 un joyau de l'art
gothique
la fente au bras de son père juan carlos
s'avancèrent son destin à séduisant
roturier basque champions de handball
il n'y a qu' au regard
devant 15 cents éviter tout le gotha de
la noblesse mondiale une quarantaine de
familles royales
la quasi-totalité du gouvernement
espagnol cristina et iñaki échanges
nourris traditionnels
[Musique]
iñaki une les bourgs soir christina
infante d'espagne que les épouses
promettre d'être fidèle dans les joies
et les peines et de la respecter tous
les jours de votre vie
merci à marc la respecter la posologie
truc
c'est qu'elle destine l'archevêque
rijkaard paris à calais ce dernier n'a
rien d'un geste alias à iñaki urdangarin
un seigneur d'être mort et finalise
at-elle le roi et la reine sofia
d'espagne
très ému
[Musique]
ah ah ah
un mariage d'amour avec tout de même une
couleur politique christina descendante
de roy épouse or hôtelier basque dans la
capitale de la catalogne
ils sauront duc et duchesse de palma de
majorque une occasion pour la monarchie
constitutionnelle de renforcer les liens
entre les 17 communautés autonomes
d'espagne
[Musique]
par mesure de prudence d'ailleurs 4000
membres des forces de sécurité veille
discrètement sur leur passage
vous serez guère le souci des rustines
et demi à qui aujourd'hui c'est l'amour
qui l'emportent
[Applaudissements]